[Music]
and for the creation and development of
the Houdini system we are proud to
present mark island and side effects
software with an Academy Award of Merit
accepting on behalf of side effects
software is kim davidson mr. alland and
mr. Davison please join us on the stage
[Applause]
sorry uh Wow it's actually a lot heavier
than it looks
I'd like to start off by thanking the
Academy since the first SciTech ceremony
in 1931 the Academy is only bestowed the
award of merit 49 times we are honored
beyond words to be receiving this award
tonight thank you
I'd like to recognize the support of my
family Trish max and Eric and like a
true Canadian I'd like to say I'm sorry
for all those late nights and miss
family dinners I'd like to thank Kim for
running side effects so that encourages
creativity innovation and
experimentation I'm I'm extremely
privileged to be standing here on stage
but really I represent the whole
development team and I'd like to thank
all of them but especially Edward lamb
mark Alexander
Rafael Andre Neill Derek Robin Lewin
Jeff Wagner Scott Keating and of course
our support leads Jenni and salvina at
one time I knew all the Houdini artists
on a first-name basis and unfortunately
that's no longer the case if you are a
Houdini artist and you ever see me
somewhere please come up and introduce
yourself because it's your art that
gives us the purpose of what we do and
now since this is the SciTech awards and
really we're all math engineers and
geeks at heart I'd like to thank working
group 21 for the huge changes to C++ 11
that reinvented the language
I'd like to thank Greedo for creating
Python but please please can you fix the
Gil and finally I'd like to thank Brian
Mullin our for trading VIN it's the only
editor I've ever used to write each and
every line of Houdini code thank you
Thank You Academy this is indeed a great
great honor I do want to thank all the
developers at side effects past and
present for creating this amazing
software I want to thank the staff at
side effects for building the culture in
the environment which we all can excel
at and of course the Houdini artists
that inspire us and continue to inspire
us to keep improving Houdini each and
every day I want to thank my wife Gayle
Wilmot for supporting me even before
there was a side effects and I showed it
to my three kids here with me today my
children Kerby Lisa and chilli you know
words really can't express the feelings
and that I have in the emotions I have
accepting this I think actually poetry
so much much better device and I'm not a
poet but I've written a short little ode
I'd like to read to you now Houdini
needs no introduction four artists can
use in production for effects that they
rave on the Academy gave an Oscar for
Houdini destruction Thank You Academy
thank you very very very much thank you
[Music]